we don't have enough people to fight in
our armies and so we import all these
illegal immigrants and then we say
that's right that's right hey you want
citizenship all you got to do is fight
for us we did it before in Civil War the
Irish but but it it is common they offer
non-citizens a path citizenship by
serving in the armed forces true that's
a pretty I mean that's not just an
American thing that's a classic thing
throughout history that Nations have
done isn't that how n like like didn't
Rome do something like that before
collapsing Rome did yeah yeah well we
did that in the Revolutionary War I
believe Civil War well the Revolutionary
War was French intervention the the
crown had the mercenaries French right
right right they had like the Hess I
remember that story we can't ask people
who came here illegally to become
citizens you guys are crazy that would
be ridiculous I'm not on board with this
plan either I think that we should
probably have like that's the policy
huge levels of deportations and just be
like no you're done like this is not
going to work out